no issue is more hotly contested today
than immigration with restriction is
calling for the deportation of all
illegals and a 50% cut in legal
immigration here are the five strongest
arguments against immigration and why
they're wrong
so with immigration you better be smart
and you better be tough and they're
taking your jobs and you better be
careful so which is it president Trump
do we have record low unemployment or
are immigrants stealing all the jobs the
worst case estimates are that
low-skilled immigrants reduce the wages
of high school dropouts by less than 5%
that's not nothing but immigrants make
things cheaper for all Americans by
doing jobs such as picking fruit or
cleaning up on construction sites the
money saved can be devoted to other
productive uses which also creates jobs
in the developed world there is no
correlation between unemployment and
immigration rates immigrants go to hot
economies and they leave when the jobs
dry up why would you want to bring
people who are immediately dependent on
welfare when they get here don't you
want people who add something
immediately to your country since the
late 90s most legal immigrants and all
illegals are barred from receiving most
forms of welfare the only real
taxpayer-funded services most immigrants
use are emergency medical treatments
that account for less than 2% of all
health care spending in K through 12
education for their children who are
often US citizens immigrants who do
qualify for programs such as Medicaid
food stamps or supplemental Social
Security use these programs at lower
rates than native-born Americans or
naturalized citizens legal immigrant men
also have a higher labor force
participation rate than natives and
illegals are even more likely to be
working than legal immigrants to here
illegally they're not paying taxes okay
I've heard this one before do I hear
them all legal immigrants pay the exact
same taxes as all Americans illegals pay
the same sales and property taxes and
between half and two-thirds also end up
paying payroll and income taxes because
they use fake social security cards and
other documents to get hired and if we
want unauthorized immigrants to
contribute more in taxes the best way to
accomplish that is to change their legal
status
I would suggest they do is that they go
back to their home country get in line
with the hundreds of thousands of people
from their home country who are trying
to do it legally for many immigrants
especially from Mexico there really is
no lie in 2010 for instance just 65,000
visas were given to Mexicans with the
overwhelming majority going to close
family members such as spouses and minor
children the wait list had one point
four million people on it effectively
meaning there is no chance of ever
getting in long wait lists also exists
for the Philippines China India and
other countries and for all the fear of
what restriction is called chain
migration family reunification consists
almost exclusively of US citizens
bringing their spouses and unmarried
minor children to live here the backlogs
for most countries means that this can
take between 15 and 25 years if you
start to bring your sister over when
she's 25 you'll be lucky to welcome her
by the time she turns 40 you should not
import people numerous enough to
influence your society change its laws
and destroy your culture exactly the
same complaints were made about
newcomers like the Irish the Jews and
the Italians yet about one-third of
Mexican immigrants marry outside their
ethnicity or race which is the same
percentage as it was a quarter century
ago successive generations also see
massive gains in household income and
home ownership rates in this TV bill
that William was proud el acento gringo
and when it comes to learning English
all signs are that Hispanics are more
likely to speak English at home than in
years past by the third generation
English is the dominant language in
three-quarters of Hispanic homes which
is the same rate of language shift seen
in earlier waves of immigration the
bottom line is that when it comes to
immigration the instincts of the
American people are correct immigrants
helped the economy and newcomers make
the land of opportunity a better place
to live
you
[Music]